Our future president... Yeah,
future president, I said it.
Start tasting that throw-up in
your mouth right now, you guys.
-(laughter and groaning)
-Right now.
(audience clapping, booing)
He's talking about
how big his dick is
in a nationally-televised
presidential debate.
I mean, sure,
Ike grabbed his balls
during his farewell address,
but he never referenced it,
all right.
-(laughter)
-That was called class.
You know what, guys?
I tell you,
the more I think
about Trump's dick joke,
the more...
the more it just pisses me off.
You know, let me make one thing
loud and clear.
-Making dick jokes is my job.
-(laughter)
A politician's job is
to make policies.
A comedian's job is
to make dick jokes.
-(laughter)
-Okay?
Crass, shame-filled,
fifth-grade-level dick jokes.
(laughter)
I've told dick jokes
for 60 years.
Yeah, I'm in my 80s.
Black don't crack, (bleep)!
(laughter)
-(applause and cheering)
-Yeah, that's right.
It may not be...
it may not be classy work,
or work I'm proud of,
but it's honest work
that puts food on my table
and a roof over my head.
I got my kids through school
on dick jokes!
-(laughter)
-All right?
-That's right. It's true.
-(applause and cheering)
Dick jokes. Trump claims
Mexico's taking our jobs.
Well, Trump's taking jobs from
hard-working, low-brow comedians
who would be nothing
without a good dick joke.
And don't give me... don't
give me that bull (bleep) line,
"All jokes matter."
(bleep) you (bleep).
-(laughter)
-It's not just me.
No, no, no, it's not just me.
Comedians everywhere
are outraged,
from prop comics in Pensacola
to stand-ups in Spokane,
and we are standing together
and starting a movement:
Dick Jokes Matter.
(laughter, whooping, applause)
Now...
just... just look at the faces
that this is affecting.
♪ ♪
This country was built
on big dreams
and small dick jokes.
And if you want my dick joke,
you'll have to rip it out
of my cold, clammy,
lightly lotioned hand.
(laughter, applause)
Dick Jokes Matter.
♪ ♪
As a woman comic-- and I start
all of my sentences that way...
(laughter)
...I don't just rely
on vadge jokes,
I tell dick jokes, too.
And I'm grateful
for all the women who before me
also told dick jokes
and broke the glass ceiling...
with their dicks.
-(laughter, whooping, applause)
-Dick matters.
♪ ♪
(cheering, applause)
I remember when I got
my first dick joke.
(laughter)
My father passed it down to me.
I was going to pass it down
to my son--
maybe not the whole thing,
but at least just the tip.
(laughter)
Dick Jokes Matter!
(cheering, applause)
That's right.
Stand with us.
Let politicians hear
your voices.
Comedy's tradition of dick jokes
is long, proud,
and yeah,
sometimes a little veiny.
So take back our dick jokes.
Dick Jokes Matter, you guys.
-(cheering, applause)
-Right? Dick Jokes Matter!
♪ Dick Jokes Matter ♪